I talked to an ocean safety expert by
the way it's your hand on my face
because I'm well cuz I roll I don't care
what fish you been hanging out as I roll
right so wrong so a grapple so I'm
getting less and less afraid of you I
really am I really am
now I hate to do this right now what I'm
staring at your hair yeah it's annoying
me yeah and him's ask me for you not no
no no I'll take there don't say that you
can see that I have a full head of hair
it's just not as thick as it could be
like yours you look like a baby Austrian
okay I don't like what you said now
let's say a couple things I talk to an
ocean scene the baby oxygen yeah talk to
an ocean safety expert asking about
ripped eyes and I got a question about
rip tides and I said art don't forget to
sharks okay so don't fight him chin what
the [ __ ] man it's just like don't pull
up baby ostrich man when I [ __ ]
Interpol's you your days scroll down
hold your big dish like that far left
the far left you guys are being good see
that's kind of less that's disrespecting
that's [ __ ] districts around baby
ostrich not don't call me that
mm-hmm so anyway I uh I was asking my
riptides anybody out there you get
caught in a Riptide
it's not gonna pull you under you're
gonna be fine let it take you
I've already covered this I know let it
take you and then swim - swim diagonal
just rely well yeah then he said I got a
bone to pick with with Shaab with your
boy shop tell him that when you see
seals in the water
let me shark sure that means there are
no sharks and I go what he was yelling
i'ma go what do you mean because because
seals know when they're sharks and they
get the [ __ ] out of there so when you
see seals it's good news get in the
water hold on huh when seals are not
there it's sketchiest [ __ ] does it make
sense yeah it does he's an expert yeah
he's a water that's where like Falchi
he's a water safety out there so let's
talk about full disclosure
folks groceries just how I card he's 22
oh wow
so you tell this 22-year old [ __ ] listen
Baywatch yeah here's the thing what do
you think sharks eat what do you what
are they yeah they eat see us another
fish they eat seals right yeah so when
there's group of seals around what do
you think would bring the Sharks near
the seal now I agree with that
personally if I see seals I'm getting
I'm not going anywhere near that but
this oceans
the expert is 22 is a lifeguard nice
wait you know what oh god I hate to do
this to my baby watch [ __ ] dude hey
watch [ __ ] I'm sorry I like that listen
a little bit he's gotta easy easy
he's got a very very thick and blond boy
he's skinny and black you can't be for
the very height goes to things too thick
okay so he's all assam tonight well get
them a bike and shut the [ __ ] up here's
the thing Kelly Slater told me seal
you'll be worried about it no huh sir
yep surfers told me this I said yep this
keys 22 yeah you put on your Tropicana
suntan lotion okay and you shut okay
you're young but sunblock is super blond
though he's blond yeah you know low-key
blue Sun oh I know him yeah great kid I
love him to death
he's a lifeguard in the oh he was a
lifeguard for a guy like a Long Beach
all doesn't count
I know I know it the gay lobby what the
[ __ ] yeah thank you [ __ ] yeah you can
easily say nothing you tell my glasses
so blue eyes that's blue eyes he looks
like the leader of antiva listen no
leader nt4 not as he looks like it no
cuz they're they're they're anti-fascist
I know but they look like him no they're
not that blonde and blue-eyed some are
he looks more like Hitler Youth he's of
course Hillary would protect him yes
he's like the point is you're too thick
to be lifeguards quick turn shuffle
lifeguard also your dad's station and
where cuz that Costanzo says don't worry
about oh yeah different places but he's
also near Iraq ha how much life Gardens
going on oh no he was here and hunt him
he grew up always stable and and
Monterey were there a lot of great
whites might agree with there was a
great white attack right oh yeah
recently like yesterday oh yeah Hayek
right no bring up no the guy died in the
shark took off and then I go well let's
save that guy in the sharklet well
what's this where the [ __ ] is this this
here in Australia
yep suffer dies after me a bit my great
white shark nearly ten feet long and
those people go well let's save the guy
in the shark went well there's more
targets and you start chasing them is
that true oh my god that scared the [ __ ]
out of me wait an a.m. on Sunday all
right shark swimming on to Costa 50 old
male has been fair attacked by shirt you
think the blame around Quran
damn curlers oh [ __ ] man do we start
wearing masks you make it I'm not
surfing there I know it's rare I'm still
not surfing there there's gotta have
drones can't they have drone - just look
for this [ __ ] all the time they do what
do you that's their home I know I know
it's true they're like don't swim here
because that we saw a shark but come
back tomorrow like the Sharks right a
big [ __ ] shark yeah I guess they
jumped on a while to save the guy in the
shark planet Oh what do we have here
isn't it weird when people jump in the
water save together the Sharks like this
is too easy
oh there's a handful of fatal shark
shark attacks in Australia oh yeah yeah
we want to be careful of that we just do
I was just video of it well there's a
curiosity right but if there's also yeah
it's so scary it's so scary things
bigger than the jet ski no thanks by the
way that's only ten feet you got old
gray and get up to 25 that's a babe okay
25 feet
whoa what an April a shark fatally
mauled a twenty three old wildlife
worker on the Great Barrier Reef again
there the reef is not good you know how
they have odds obviously all statistics
are skewed but it'd be like you're more
likely hit by lightning than dying don't
care a shark will hold on you're more
likely to get hit by lightning and dive
from Crona if you're under 36 no
underlying health conditions that's a
real one but you're more like you died
with your odds go up if you're surfing
than every day of your ads are bladers
they do so for all those surfers like
dude you're more like you're dying the
way driving here mm-hmm
if you live in the water your odds go
Scott sir for like you and me I haven't
been the beach but maybe the reason
they're so rarest cuz we don't spend a
lot human beings don't spend a lot of
time in the water especially cold water
where there are great whites unless
you're a surfer you know and then you're
on a board and all that but you know I
would imagine if you're swimming around
all the time something's gonna happen
yeah be a manatee go it'd be a bad way
to go I mean if there
seals they do take off so there was a
guy who got his leg bitten off by a
great white he was he was a scuba diving
with seals and he said and all of a
sudden they just disappeared they just
all went to me they scattered he's alone
he was that's weird
cuz old gray came in and went and it
will be 20-foot I'll take that well he
thought yeah guy didn't give me that leg
right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue oh good what's gonna happen what
are you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[Laughter]